(high energy music)
- Hi my name is Kelsey and I like to eat.
I'm confident in my skills as a foodie.
I watch a lot of those
Netflix cooking shows.
I think we'll be fine,
how hard can this be?
- My name is Adam Fleischman,
I'm a chef restaurateur.
I'm the founder of Umami Burger.
I've been cooking
burgers for 10 years now.
And I'm pretty confident
that I can come up
with something, I would do so great here.
I'm an improvisational chef so
gonna make it up on the spot.
It'll get chaotic in here.
Alright let's get started.
(thumping music)
- [Director] Go.
- I want the good one.
(Adam laughs)
- Hey I need one.
- Kay, first I'm heating up my candle
aka my oven to melt the butter.
- This is a wack candle.
- Wow complaining already
all I hear is excuses,
you know what I'm saying.
Are you that kind of chef
that eats while he cooks.
- Yep.
- Same.
Oh look my onions are cooking.
This is insane how this actually works.
(sizzle)
- Ooh I got a sizzle.
- Did you hear that
sizzle, can I have some?
- Yeah, that's the good stuff.
That's what they give
you at the airplanes.
Oh yours smells good.
- Does it?
See aren't you supposed
to do salt from high
so that it spreads further?
- Yeah you wanna rain it on there.
- Rain it salt bae, wait yeah salt bae it.
Can I do this with my fingers?
Will that be smarter probably?
Are you putting avocados on burgers?
- I'm not a fan of it.
- I am not either and I said that
'cause we're in California
and people put avocado
in everything it's just obnoxious.
I think I have tinier fingers
therefore better tiny skills,
therefore better tiny chef.
Ahh, my onions are burning.
Oh no, aah.
- [Adam] We got our first burn.
- Shit.
Don't look at my mess, I'm embarrassed.
I think I need more wine.
- I'm making my bun here
with my homemade crust.
- Why are circles the
hardest shape to make?
- Uh, they have no corners.
Genius, (Adam laughs) I gotta
hang out with this guy more.
- We use this little circular
ring molds like all you need
to really do is just do
that and just kinda go boop.
- Nice, look at that a perfect circle.
- Wanna taste my Umami sauce?
(Adam chuckles) Still working.
- My god, that's delicious.
(Adam laughs)
Bacon, I forgot about bacon.
- Look at my bun.
It's so pretty.
One thing we have go enforce
never make a burger on a grill.
I know people do it
- What?
- 'cause you don't get
even heat distribution
and all the flavor just
kinda falls into the grill.
If you're gonna cook on the
grill just take a cast iron pan,
put it on your barbecue.
I judged a burger competition
once with Hell's Kitchen.
- What?
- It was--
- How was that?
- No one could cook, I'm
sure yours will be better.
Here's my secret right here.
- Wow an innovator.
(Adam chuckles)
I'm gonna put a little
bit of mayonnaise on this.
Do you like mayonnaise on
burgers or it disgusts--
- I do, I do.
- You do okay.
- Mustard and ketchup really
don't have a place on a burger.
- Whoa that's a bold statement.
- I think mustard is best on hotdogs.
- This is gonna be the difference
between mine and yours.
People are gonna go wow
really thought about this.
- Wow, undercooked bacon.
- This is gonna get dangerous.
(Kelsey screams)
we have a fire.
- I went my finger on fire.
(Kelsey laughs)
All good.
- Now do you make burgers
for any famous people
that come in your restaurant?
- All the time.
(timer beeps)
- Fuck, yours are pretty.
We almost died in the making
but we did it damn it.
- Did it.
- They just look like you
whole punched a burger bun.
- Okay they're both very
tiny, I love tiny things.
- So this one I'm gonna try
first and it has a little thing
to put on top of it which
makes me feel booshie.
- Predominantly taste
like cheese but it's good,
it taste like a little
tiny slider, I like it.
- The flavors though are pretty good.
I don't know, I feel
pretty mad about that one.
- I think this little
sauce made a difference.
Wow this is good.
- Whoever made this
one has more confidence
because they didn't need a topping.
- It's stacked very neatly.
- You got some green, you got
some yellow, you got some red.
Oh.
- I like this one a lot.
(ding) That's my winner.
- Sometimes simple is better.
(ding) I like this one.
- This one to me is more savory.
(ding) I'll say this one.
- I am fucking shooketh.
(lively music)